We will fight for this France
who has nothing more than homework
but who nevertheless has rights,
this rural France.
Rurality has almost become a swear word.
Being a rural person is almost like being a bastard.
These files that have less attention today
than these S files,
rural people.
Join us,
support us,
it's for you that we do all this
and people will know who we are and that we
exist.
The rural areas were there before Europe,
they will still be after them.
Our values are immutable,
they have crossed the centuries.
We will only be passengers of your word,
of your values
and we will
make it remain in the European marble
and that she never comes out again.